RACHEL DEACON-SMITH:
Today we're going
to give you a very quick
talk on BigQuery GIS.
So, looking at the
agenda, we'll give you
a very brief introduction
into BigQuery GIS So,
what exactly is it?
And some of the data
types around it.
And then we will spend
the bulk of the time
giving you guys a demo,
so showcasing the features
and showing you some of
the example use cases.
You have three speakers
today, Kannappan, Thinh,
and myself, Rachel.
We are all a strategic
cloud engineers
based in the London office.
OK, so BigQuery.
For those that do not know,
BigQuery is Google Cloud's data
enterprise data warehouse.
It can manage large data.
So, we manage storage
on the petabyte scale
and you can run analysis on
up to billions and billions
of growths.
You can interact with
BigQuery using SQL.
And it's fully managed
and serverless,
so you don't have to worry
about spinning up clusters
and managing resources.
That's all done for you.
The idea that you load the
data, run your analysis.
It's super big,
it's super quick.
So then we move on
to BigQuery GIS.
So GIS is Geospatial
Information Systems.
And BigQuery is one of
the first cloud providers
to offer an MPP, massively
parallel processing data
warehouse that supports
geospatial functions and data
types.
So we have the concept
of a geography data type,
and that's essentially a point
set on the Earth's surface.
And when you combine that
with your location data
in your BigQuery table--
so, for example, if
you have longitude
and latitude or country codes--
you can essentially derive
really powerful insight.
It makes your data
lot more relatable.
Underpinning this all
is the same library
used in Google Maps.
And we also have the
BigQuery visualization tool
which is a lightweight
tool that allows
you to view your analysis
against a live map.
So I mentioned the
geography data type.
And I said this
represents a point set
on the Earth's surface.
So by points set this can
be an actual like point
on the surface or a set
of points, so a line
string or a polygon.
And we'll see this in
action in the demo.
You also have GIS
functions and types.
And if you're
familiar with PostGIS
you'll be familiar with this.
And these essentially
just operate
on the geography data type.
Enough talking, I think.
Let's hand over to
Kanna, who will do a demo
and show you some of
these features in action.
KANNAPPAN SIRCHABESAN: OK.
Hi, welcome everyone.
So I'm doing a demo
of, like the data
types and the functions that are
available within BigQuery GIS.
So this, like we are
starting with a blank slate.
So on the left side, you have
the query and on the right side
you have the map.
So this is like a visualization
tool as part of BigQuery.
So it's got query Geo Viz.
So what we are doing
now is, basically, we
are starting from scratch.
So we are drawing a
point of where we are.
So we are in Moscone Center.
So, the function we use is
s t underscore geogpoint
and we provide the lat and long.
So, as you can see, we have the
Moscone Center on the right.
So, yeah, this is one point.
Now we are going to
draw one more point.
So this is the baseball
stadium, Oracle Park.
So, as you can
see, like, the s t
underscore geogpoint
takes like two parameters.
The longitude first and then the
latitude, just the convention.
So what you see now
is, basically, you
have, like both the points
using the union hall method.
And now we are going to
connect both the points using
s t underscore makeline.
And I do yonan all again
so that I display the line
on the dot on the two points.
OK.
Now we are going to draw like
a polygon of three points,
using Google SF office
as the third point.
And what we use here is s
t underscore makepolygon.
And we use the job
from text function.
And then we draw a polygon.
OK, once we have
the polygon, now we
can do all the other measures
like distance perimeter,
and so on.
So what I've shown
here is that centroid.
What you're seeing
now is basically
the public data sets that are
available within BigQuery.
So the one that is shown here
is basically the bike data set,
the Ford GoBike.
So these are the bike
stations that are available.
So as we can see, there
are like three clusters.
So this is the cluster
in San Francisco.
So these are all
the bike stations.
Now let's filter to
the bike stations
that are within that specific
polygon, using the function
s t within.
S t stands for
spatial types which is
a common terminology in geog.
So, as you can see, there
also like a street view.
So I just clicked on
one of the points.
And as you can see,
you can see the Ford
go bike station with the bikes.
So this is like a
complex polygon.
So it's basically the zip code.
So you can get the zip code data
set, your zip code data set,
from the BigQuery
public data sets.
So what we see now here is--
So this is like, all
the bike stations.
So yeah, this is like
the cluster of points.
So what this cluster represents
is the size of the circle,
represents the
number of bikes that
are available within that
specific bike station.
So, if the circle
is bigger, which
means that there are a lot
of bikes, and if it's smaller
it means it's a less
number of bikes.
And what you're going to see
now is basically from Moscone
within a 500 meter radius
what other bike stations
that are available.
So these are some
of the bike stations
that are available within
a 500 meter distance.
Find a meter radius.
So, as you can see, that
is one very close by,
in front of like the Whole
Foods just right outside.
OK?
So, as you can
see, it's like very
easy to actually do all this
like basic methods and data
types.
So you can start using
it to do very complex
geospatial functionalities.
Thank you.
THINH HA: Thanks, Kanna.
So, for my demo,
I'm going to talk
about how you can use some
of the functionalities we
discussed for analysis,
for fun and profit.
Keeping with the
cycle higher data set,
I'm going to move
across the Atlantic
to London where we're based.
I'm going to also take the view
of the operator of the cycle
highway service.
So, as operator, I want to know
what do people use the cycle
service for.
And I like my drawing
the 50 most common path
that's taken by my service.
I can see that most of the path
is happening around Hyde Park.
So Hyde Park is a big station.
It's a big park
in central London
that's very popular
with tourists.
What this tells me is that
people are using this service
quite a lot for tourism.
So, looking at the
previous analysis,
I can see that some stations
are more frequently used
as a destination i.e.
more bikes arrive
at that attestation than no
bike starting from that station.
So this may cause some
capacity problems.
If I'm a tourist arriving
at the station that's
very frequently used, I might
not find a docking station.
So I want to do some
analysis of this trend.
What I've done here is I've
counted the number of trips
that started at the
station and subtracted it
from the number of trips
that end at that station,
and plotted on a map.
Red means there are
more trips starting
from that station
and blue means there
are more trips ending
at that station.
Looking at the station
with the biggest disparity,
I can see that corresponds
to hop exchange
to Borough, which
is where I know
there's a big farmer's
market that's also
very popular with tourists.
So, with this
knowledge, I can start
making some changes to
accommodate for this trend.
This also make me
ask the question,
do people use this cycle
service for commute at all?
So, by isolating
the trips to hours
in the morning versus
evening commute,
I can immediately see a
trend where in the morning
most people are using
the service to commute
into central London and
vise versa in the evening.
This is most pronounced
at King's Cross Station,
which you might have
heard from Harry Potter.
It's also a big
commute spot where
for everybody outside
of London commuting in.
So, personally, I also like
to go to Borough Market
in the weekend.
I know that I won't be
able to dock my bike.
That's a very
common destination.
So what I can do is I can find
the 10 closest station nearby
and immediately I can
see that the closest
station is Park Street
bank side, which
is about 164 meters away.
Thank you.
RACHEL DEACON-SMITH: Thank you.
Just to quickly wrap
up, hopefully you guys
have seen how you can
harness big data with GIS
to derive insights and make
your data bit more relational.
Don't take our word for it.
We have a few links
on the slides where
you can go and have a play.
It's currently in beta,
but, as you've just seen,
there's a lot you can play with
and familiarize yourself with.
Thank you so much for
attending and for listening.